possible for someone to grow and learn
and be better after making mistakes many
many years ago um so that's what I'm
going to do um laughter what's your
analysis she lied this summer to people
about really horrible things that she
did it doesn't sound like it was years
ago like Trisha literally on her show
said that she asked Colleen did you send
my nudes to Miners And she said nope
they sent them to me oh she blamed it on
the kids yes and that was not years ago
that's horrible and that's something
specific that like your victims would
like to hear an apology for it feels
fake because she's apologizing in this
video to who but then there's like Adam
and Becky and Oliver and all of these
people who say they haven't gotten
anything from her she's apologizing to
her fans yeah she's not apologizing to
the victims